hallo meine Lieben heute gibt es einen
Russischen Zupfkuchen aber nicht in der
normalen Variante so wie ich ihn schon
auf meinem Kanal habe sondern zu 100%
vegan ich möchte jetzt einfach mal auf
eure Kommentare eingehen und viele
Rezepte veganisieren bzw zeigen wie man
sie vegan hinbekommt wenn euch also
jetzt ein Rezept einfällt was ihr
unbedingt mal in vegan sehen wolltet
dann schreibt es unten in die Kommentare
und ich würde mal sagen wir gehen jetzt
direkt an die Zubereitung jetzt machen
wir zu allererst den schokomöbeteig der
kommt ja auf dem Boden an den Rand und
als gezupft Streusel quasi oben drüber
und das ist ganz ganz leicht vegan
hinzubekommen denn ihr könnt ja einfach
Butter durch Margarine austauschen Milch
durch Milchersatz wie z.B Haferdrink
mandeldrink es gibt ja so viele
Alternativen mittlerweile und Mehl
Zucker und Backkakao sind ja sowieso
vegan ich mache das wenn ich faau bin
zugegebenermaßen mit der Küchenmaschine
aber ich zeig euch dass das Ganze Rezept
auch komplett ohne Maschine geht dafür
gebe ich jetzt erstmal Mehl hier auf
meine Arbeitsfläche daf die Silikonmatte
einfach drunter damit nichts anklebt
Zucker gebe ich direkt mit rein
Backkakao das ist der stark entölte also
nicht der trinkkakao wo schon Zucker und
so weiter zugesetzt ist und das einfach
mit den sauberen Händen so ein bisschen
vermengen dann gebt ihr Margarine oder
eben vegane Butter mit dazu und die
sollte am besten schön weich sein also
ein paar Stunden vorher aus dem
Kühlschrank nehmen und dann gibt auch
noch schluckweise die vegane
milchalternative dazu das ganze wird
dann schön verknetet bis ein Teig
entsteht der nicht mehr
[Musik]
klebt
so der Teig ist fertig die 24er
Springform habe ich auch schon mit
Backpapier ausgekleidet und jetzt nehmen
wir uns etwa ein Drittel gerne auch Mini
bisschen weniger weg und lassen das
beiseite das kommt nämlich gleich on top
für unsere Streusel und aus dem Rest
dann nehme ich jetzt auch wieder
ungefähr zwei Drittel Weg für den Boden
und da wird jetzt einmal der Boden
komplett ausgekleidet und der Rand
hochgezogen das geht auch alles ganz
einfach ohne jegliches Equipment ein
einfach mit den Fingern flach
[Musik]
andrücken der Rand ist ungefähr 3inh cm
hoch und ihr könnt auch immer ganz
vorsichtig mit einem Messer den Rand
gerade abschneiden und dann den
Überschuss wieder dran machen einfach
damit es ein schöner gerader Abschluss
ist das kommt jetzt bis zur
Weiterverarbeitung in den Kühlschrank
genauso wie der restteig den wir gleich
z zupfen benötigen und ich zeige euch
jetzt die vegane cheesecakeemasse bis
gleich für die cheesecakeemasse brauchen
wir auch nur sechs Zutaten und ihr wisst
ja dass ich eigentlich be meinen
Cheesecakes immer ganz gerne
Philadelphia doppelrahenfischkäse
verwende jetzt ist es natürlich so dass
wir ein veganes Rezept machen aber es
gibt Philadelphia in vegan also rein
pflanzlich auf Basis von Mandel und
Hafer und das gebe ich jetzt hier in
meine große Schüssel und gibt dann die
weiteren Zutaten dazu also ganz
entspannend wie gesagt ihr braucht hier
kein Gerät kein Küchengerät oder
irgendetwas was ihr vielleicht nicht da
haben könntet und dann rühren wir das
alles schön klimpchen frei ich habe hier
noch Zucker ein bisschen Speisestärke
für die Bindung eine vegane
milchalternative und was ich finde was
immer ganz gut passt ist Zitrone und
[Musik]
Vanille wisst ihr was mir so gut gefällt
an dem pflanzlichen Philadelphia der ist
halt nicht so trocken also ich weiß
nicht ob ihr es hier schon erkennen
könnt aber der ist ultra cremig und das
ist halt wirklich die perfekte Basis für
Cheesecakes jeglicher Art und wenn ihr
das mal pur probiert macht das gerne mal
das zergeht richtig im
[Musik]
Mund bei der Zitrone ist jetzt wichtig
dass die Bio ist weil dann könnt ihr
nämlich die Schale auch mitverwerten und
die gibt noch mal so ein richtig schönes
Aroma und da reibe ich jetzt nur die
gelbe Schale unter der gelben Schale
verbirgt sich eine weiße Schale die
dürft ihr nicht mitreiben das Problem
ist dass sonst der ganze geschmack
bitter wird und dann kann man das halt
leider nicht mehr retten so die Schale
habe ich mir jetzt hier komplett
abgerieben jetzt wird die Zitrone
halbiert und da gebe ich jetzt noch mal
den kompletten Saft mit
[Musik]
rein
die cheesecakeemasse habe ich jetzt
einfach in den Teig gegeben und jetzt
haben wir noch hier den Rest vom
möbelteig der wird jetzt einfach so
drauf gezupft und der sinkt jetzt auch
nicht ein oder so die Konsistenz von der
cheesecakeemasse ist perfekt und das Bib
jetzt einfach hier auf der Oberfläche
den Ofen habe ich auch schon vorgeheizt
diesmal 170° Umluft wenn ihr jetzt keine
Umluftfunktion habt dann könnt ihr
einfach 190° Ober und unterhitzen nehmen
ihr braucht an der Stelle ein bisschen
Geduld aber die geduld zahlt sich aus
denn der ganz Kuchen wird jetzt 70
Minuten lang gebacken also eine Stunde
und 10 Minuten und danach am besten mit
offener Ofentür im Ofen auskühlen lassen
und anschließend noch mal für einige
Stunden in den Kühlschrank stellen ihr
merkt schon das ist so ein Rezept das
könnt ihr perfekt am Vortag vorbereiten
nach der Kühlzeit können wir dann einmal
die Springform lösen am besten nehmt ihr
euch dafür eine schmale Winkelpalette
und geht ganz vorsichtig am Rand entlang
damit da auch nichts kleben bleibt ich
habe mir auch schon mein cakeboard
rausgeholt damit wir das einmal komplett
entfernen auch vom Boden Klammer einmal
öffnen sehr schön also optisch finde ich
erkennt man jetzt auch nicht den
Unterschied zwischen einem veganen und
einem nicht veganen Zupfkuchen so jetzt
einmal ganz vorsichtig hier unten
drunter auch sehr ich muss sagen
pflegeleicht was das Anheben angeht es
gibt ja echt so Tortenrezepte da ist man
so kriege ich das jetzt angehoben aber
hier durch den Mürbeteig ist es echt
entspannend jetzt gebe ich das hier
einmal auf so eine schöne so schönen
Untergrund so fertig wir machen jetzt
noch hübsche Fotos und dann sehen wir
uns gleich zum Tast Test
[Musik]
wieder so jetzt mache ich noch den Taste
Test für euch und ich finde auch im
Anschnitt würde man jetzt nicht denken
wenn das auf dem kuchenbefehl steht dass
das jetzt ein komplett veganer Kuchen
ist so und jetzt wir man probiert das
coole ist übrigens der ist echt locker
45 Tage haltbar also ihr könnt ihn
wirklich im Voraus zubereiten und noch
einige Tage davon essen
ne der schmeckt nicht vegan also ich bin
richtig begeistert ich muss sagen also
ganz ganz ehrlich man sieht nicht dass
er vegan ist oder man schmeckt also man
schmeckt auch gar nicht das einzige was
man so ein bisschen rausschmeckt ist im
Abgang so eine leichte Mandelnote die
dann vom Frischkäse kommt aber super
cremig sehr sehr frisch also auch mit
der Zitrone die ich reingegeben habe
passt perfekt Vanille Geschmack kommt
raus mega bin begeistert ich kann jetzt
absolut vegan Besuch empfahren und kann
sowas tolles servieren ich werde mir das
ganze jetzt noch mit einem schönen
heißen Kaffee genehmigen ich glaube der
hier ist schon kalt geworden aber ich
mache mir jetzt noch mal ein schönen
Kaffee dazu dann Tee gönn mir das guck
mal jetzt ist auch noch die Sonne
rausgekommen perfektes Timing also
macht's gut bis zum nächsten
[Musik]
Mal